- Good afternoon.
I'm Alyssa Goodman.
I'm one of the
co-directors for science
here at the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
And so I have the privilege
of welcoming all of you
and also welcoming the many from
the crew of the Tara vessel,
which you will hear all
about this afternoon
from Eric Karsenti.
I'm not going to introduce Eric.
I'm going to introduce
Chris Bowler, who's
going to introduce Eric.
And so before I
do that, I should
explain that this event is
part of a series of events
that goes under the general
title of "The Undiscovered."
And what we mean by
"The Undiscovered,"
for this year at Radcliffe, is
discoveries that are very, very
hard to anticipate.
So for example, you go out
to measure the deceleration
of the universe with a lot of
telescopes and a lot of people.
And you accidentally measure
the acceleration of the universe
and win a Nobel Prize.
Or you go out and
there is 15,000 species
of plankton known and you
sequence a lot of stuff.
And you wind up with
10 times that many.
But I don't want to steal
Eric or Chris' thunder.
So I won't tell you
anything more about that.
What I would like to say
is that I'm really, really
honored that this all came
to be and that Tara is here.
And I should explain
that Chris Bowler--
who I'm about to
tell you about--
and I were fellows together
at the Radcliffe Institute
a couple of years ago.
And we knew that Tara-- the
vessel that's moored in Boston
Harbor now and you
can go see it--
was going to be making
this big world tour.
And we thought,
wouldn't it be great
if we could bring the Tara
mission here to Radcliffe,
and let you hear
about it from Eric,
and let you experience its
educational aspects by going
to the ship?
And I'm sure Eric will say
more about all of that.
And so I'm just really glad
that that has come to fruition.
And I invite you to come to more
of these "Undiscovered" events.
And the big annual
science symposium
that will cover many
topics in science
is on the 26th of October,
as it says somewhere
in the fine print.
And then that next
slide is my final point
here before telling you
a little bit about Chris,
which is I'm an astronomer.
I forgot to mention that.
And we're kind of
embarrassed that--
you see that little
tiny blue piece
that says "ordinary matter"?
That's what we actually can
observe in the universe.
And then we knew that we made
one mistake, which was we
left out all this stuff
that's called dark matter.
And then that discovery I
told you about a minute ago,
where there was the
acceleration instead
of the deceleration
of the universe--
that was when we needed to
invent this funny thing called
dark energy, which we
have no idea what that is.
OK, so when we say "the
undiscovered" or "the unknown,"
It's basically everything
that's green and orange
in that picture.
Now interestingly,
what I've known--
what I've learned, rather, in
the very recent past about life
sciences and about
the work of Tara,
gives you the bottom
half of this diagram,
which looks oddly similar.
And for those of you who
are not biology experts,
we go in the little slice called
"eukarya," which also includes
things like plants and yeast.
And so it's not even just us.
And so all that other stuff
is bacteria, and viruses,
and other things that
you'll hear about today.
And mostly, we
didn't know about it
until we sequenced large
fractions of the ocean, which
you will hear
plenty about today.
So anyway, I think
it's remarkable
that a lot of science,
especially today,
is, let's say, data
that will tell us
something about our universe
and our world in the future.
But that we [AUDIO OUT]
don't understand.
And so part of the mission
of this "Undiscovered" theme
is to explain that if science
were taught a little bit more
like that, it might
seem more exciting.
Of course, we run the risk
of sounding like we don't
know what we're talking about.
But we try not to do that.
So anyway, before
I ramble on more,
let me just tell
you that I'm really
pleased to have
Chris Bowler here.
And I'll just tell
you briefly that he
is the CNRS Director of Research
at the Institut de Biologie--
half English, half French--
de l'Ecole Normale
Superieure in Paris.
And he himself is
someone who uses
genomics approaches to study
plants, and phytoplankton,
and particular diatoms.
And so he's much
more expert than I
to introduce Eric and his work.
And he also serves as a
scientific coordinator
for the Tara expeditions
that you'll hear about today.
So thank you.
And Chris, I turn
it over to you.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Thank you, Alyssa.
So as Alyssa mentioned, I'm
normally based in Paris.
I had the fortune
and the honor to be
a Radcliffe fellow a couple
of years ago here in Harvard,
where I met Alyssa.
And that's when we first
started talking about Tara.
And it's really the
realization of a dream today
that Tara is in town.
Tara is docked down close
to the New England Aquarium
after a two year expedition.
And Eric Karsenti is
here with us today
to present today's lecture.
So that's a fantastic
combination of events,
of circumstances.
And thank you so much
for coming here and being
interested to hear more.
So, to introduce
Eric, Eric got his PhD
from the Pasteur
Institute in Paris.
He then went to San
Francisco, UCSF,
to do a postdoc with
Mark Kushner, who
is here somewhere--
Harvard faculty since
25 years, I think.
Did you tell me yesterday?
Yeah.
So it's, again, a combination of
stars that come together today
with Mark being here as well.
So following the postdoc at
UCSF, Eric went back to Europe
and worked, in particular, at
the European Molecular Biology
Laboratory in Heidelberg,
which is the European center
of molecular
biology, with, today,
about two and a half
thousand people working
there or something.
And Eric was the Director
of the Cell Biology Program
at EMBL for 15 years.
So he set up the Cell
Biology Program over there,
and during that
time, made all kinds
of fundamental discoveries
about how cells work--
the mechanics of the
cells, the physics
of interacting with the
biology of individual cells--
and made all kinds of wonderful
contributions to that field.
At the same time, Eric
was also a sailor.
He loved sailing.
He's passionate
about sailing and was
finally able to combine
his passion for biology
with his passion for sailing
through the interaction
with the Tara
Expeditions Foundation.
Through this
collaboration together,
Eric has set up a scientific
program based upon the research
schooner that he will introduce
to you to understand more
about life in the ocean.
And, as you will
see from his talk,
you will see how he's able
to combine his expertise
in understanding cell
biology through a physical
perspective-- perspective
of physics of the system,
how he's brought that thinking
into understanding of life
in the ocean and where
life in the ocean
came from, from an
evolutionary point of view,
way back to the
beginnings of time.
So it's a fantastic combination
of a very high-level cell
biology with understanding
of ocean processes.
So we have been working
together for 10 years now
on the Tara Oceans Project.
It's very far from finishing.
We still have a
lot of work to do.
But we've already done a
lot of things together.
And Eric has received many
accolades over recent years.
He won the gold
medal of the CNRS
from the CNRS in France,
which is the highest
accolade for science in France.
He won that in 2015.
And he's won several
other medals, as well,
for his scientific
achievements--
to the extent today that
some people in France
talk about Tara as
the new Calypso.
And some people talk about
Eric as the modern day Darwin.
So I'm sure he's going to
entertain you for the next 45
minutes or so, giving
you his view about life
on our beautiful planet
and in the oceans.
Thank you, Eric.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
So it's very nice to be here.
I like this place and this
town, and especially being in--
you know I'm living on
Tara right now, so--
living in the harbor.
So it's really nice.
I can walk around as if
I was a Boston citizen.
So, yes.
So thank you, Chris, for
this beautiful introduction
Yes, today what I want to
do is to talk to you about--
I know that this is
very general audience,
so I try to make a general talk.
And I will talk about my
previous work on the cells,
actually, as Chris said before.
And after that I will
come to Tara Oceans.
There is a link between the two.
I will try to show you how this
is connected, at least for me--
how I see this connection.
So you know, we all
start as a round ball.
We are an embryo.
This is a frog egg.
You know that I worked on
this in Mark's lab, actually.
I will show you some
experiments we did with this.
And this cell divides
many, many times--
thousands of times.
And then it makes an organism.
What is absolutely amazing
is that it's very complex.
An embryo is extremely complex.
There are lots of
complicated processes
that are going on
during the development.
And this is why,
very often, people
think that there is a god that
should have generated this.
But as scientists,
we try to-- even
if there is a god somewhere--
we are trying to understand
how this actually forms.
So when the divides the
first sets cells in general,
and the first cells of the
embryo, they make a spindle.
So you see here the
chromosomes condense.
You see the chromosomes
in red here.
They contain the
genetic information.
The mitotic spindle is a
machine which is made of tubes--
small tubes-- that segregate the
chromosomes to the two daughter
cells.
So when you look
at this again, it's
even more fascinating than just
looking at the embryo dividing.
You see the precision with which
the chromosome are segregated.
There is almost never a mistake.
And yet this is a
very dynamic process.
And these are tubes
that organize themselves
into complex, very functional
structure-- a machine.
So these days, a lot of people
think that life is DNA--
that the DNA
contains information
and that this is directing
the organization.
But It's more complex than this.
And in fact, I just
want to go back
to philosophy a little bit.
And Kant already was thinking
about this in his book
on the critics of judgment.
And he said, in an
organism, organ functions
emerge from properties
of parts and the whole.
So this is interesting, because
very often in modern science
we are working in a
very reductionist way.
We think one thing does
something, which does the next.
But he understood that it was
more complicated than this.
And that we need to understand
the whole and the parts
to understand our
living system functions.
And living matter is therefore
a self-organized end.
And this was the first
time that somebody
talked about
self-organization, which
is a philosophical concept.
This reasoning led
Kant to question
the use of classical causality
principle to explain life.
And he suggested that
a new type of science
would be necessary to
explain how end and means are
interconnected.
So when I read this,
I liked it a lot,
because this is
really the problem.
We have to crack this problem.
So somebody else, also,
was a great thinker,
Erwin Schrodinger.
And he gave a series of
lectures in the 1940s
in Trinity College.
And he said some things
which are very interesting.
He said, how can the
events in space and time
which take place within the
special boundary of a living
organism be accounted for
by physics and chemistry.
Because he thought
that we should
be able to extend life in
terms of physics and chemistry.
There obvious inability
of present day physics
and chemistry to
account for such events
is no reason for doubting
that they can be accounted
for by those sciences.
So obviously, this is
what we think here.
But at the time, it
was not so obvious.
So and then, there
are two sentences
which are very interesting.
He says there are two ways of
producing orderliness in living
matter-- order from disorder--
since he was a specialist
of statistical physics
or statistical mechanism,
which is known to physicists,
he was not so surprised about
this--
but the other one was
the order from order--
so cell duplication.
And that seemed to be
more complicated to him.
He suggested that-- at the
time we did not know about DNA,
he suggested that there was
something in living matter
which was he called the
aperiodic crystal, which
in fact, now we know is the DNA.
So now we know the origin of
living matter organization.
We have to think it
in two different ways.
One is statistical
mechanics-- how
collective behavior leads to
emerging functions and systems.
And the aperiodic crystal is
a [INAUDIBLE] self-duplication
of the DNA molecule.
So the DNA molecule is to be
seen, really, as something
which has information in it.
But it doesn't
really direct things.
It generates the
production of molecules
which have information.
But these molecules have to
interact, and interact somehow
collectively and stochastically
to generate complex patterns.
So now if we think about
life, not only now,
but in a very general context--
so from the context of
evolution and of local events--
I think the DNA
kind of links both.
Because the DNA has
the memory of what
happened over four billion
years during the evolution.
And there was a lot
of complexification
during this time of the DNA, but
of cells or so, and organisms.
At our time scale, we have
to understand how our cells
and organisms get organized.
But this also comes
from the origin of order
at the evolutionary level.
So it's just that there
are lots of things
happening during a long time
which are kept in the DNA.
And at our time
scales, the molecules
which are, at a given
time, in the cells
get organized into complex
functional systems.
So just to show you something
about the question of evolution
at the level of organism, one
of the big questions, also--
for example, for
Darwin and Lamarck--
they were discussing a lot
about the origin of the eye.
Eyes are striking, because
they are a beautiful structure,
extremely precise.
They function very well.
And how can this come about?
And obviously, at the
time, they did not
have much ways of understanding
all these structures.
That's why you develop the
theory of evolution with--
you know we did not know
about mutations, variations,
and selection.
But in fact, there are
many different eyes.
You see that these eyes of
the eyes of a bird, which
are very much like ours.
They are like a
photographic system.
But there are the
eyes of insects,
which have multiple facets.
Here, these are eyes into
a clam or a shellfish.
I don't remember exactly.
There are many eyes
on the edge here.
And this is a primitive
worm, a flatworm.
They are very, very
simple eyes here.
So the eyes have developed
in different ways.
But they always are used to get
light and inform the organism
of the light that comes.
But they took very
different shapes.
So now before going into this--
I will come back that
after Tara Oceans--
I want to say something
on the origin of order
at the cell level.
So at the level
at our time scale.
And I will start
with experiments
made by Mark and
by me, actually,
using the cell cycle and
assembly of the mitotic spindle
as an example to understand
how morphogenesis
can happen at the cell level.
So there are two questions
about morphogenesis.
One is time-- how time
is determined in cells.
And the other is shapes--
patterns in space.
So this is just a
beautiful experiment.
That actually drove me
to go to Mark's lab.
He showed this movie
in Berlin in 1981.
And I really was struck by this.
So he showed-- this is
a frog egg, actually,
that has not been fertilized.
So they have removed the
nucleus from this egg.
There is no cytoskeleton,
no centrioles in there.
So they cannot
divide physically.
But what you can do is prick
the egg with a fine needle.
And this starts the cell cycle.
So you see, the egg
contracts every 30 minutes,
very regularly.
And this shows that there is a
clock somewhere in this cell.
There is a clock
going on, ticking.
And at the time, we had
no idea what it could be.
It's very interesting, because--
I remember, at this time
it was really exciting,
because it was a mystery.
We didn't know how this could
function, generate a very, very
precise time like this.
So I don't go into
the details of this,
because this is a long
story-- complicated.
But I'll just show
you the principle.
So the clock turned out to
be in fact a circular system.
So you have an
inactive regulator
of the cell, which
can be activated
by an activator, which is
synthesized continuously
in the cytoplasm of the egg.
This activator, by combining
with the regulator,
activates it.
And this one does
a lot of things--
I will show you--
on the cytoplasm of the
cell and changes its shape.
Then, in the same
time, this complex
activates its own
degradation, the degradation
of the activator, so that
the clock can go back
into its original state.
So this is an oscillator.
And I show you this, because
this is a general principle
in biology, this loop.
There are lots of
feedback loops and systems
that are feeding
back on themselves.
And this is part of
self-organization principles,
actually.
So what does this
active thing do?
Well, it does something
very interesting.
Because what happens in
interphase-- you know,
when the cells don't divide--
they have a nucleus.
So you see the nucleus
here and the cytoplasm.
And in the cytoplasm, there
are tubes, the microtubules,
which are nucleated by
the centrosome here.
When the regulator
gets activated
it changes the state
of the cytoplasm.
So it switches
just one molecule,
which changes the state of
the cytoplasm in such a way
that instead of making an
astral array of microtubules,
it makes a bipolar spindle.
So the centrioles duplicate.
They go at the two
poles of the spindle.
And the microtubules
get reorganized
into bipolar spindles,
the function of which
is to segregate the chromosomes
to the two poles of the cell.
So you see this
is really amazing.
It's a very complicated system.
There is a clock that
changes the state of the cell
so that it can divide and
segregate its chromosomes.
So it's very
important, because this
is the mechanism by which the
information which is in the DNA
is transmitted to
the dividing cells.
Now, this is the clock.
It works in fact because--
so this is the activator.
This is the inactive
molecule of the clock.
And it becomes
activated abruptly here.
So there's a positive feedback
loop here, a negative feedback
loop, and then the regulator
gets degraded, and so on.
So you get, really, an
oscillation this way.
And each time, what
happens when this becomes
activated-- you get
a mitotic spindle.
So the next question
was actually,
how do you assemble a spindle
like this with microtubules
around the chromosomes?
So this is interesting, because
this is a machine, actually,
that segregates the chromosomes.
So how do the machines
can get assembled?
So that's another experiment
I did in Mark's lab.
So I put "The French Connection
and the Bay of Pigs."
This is a joke, because
when I came to Mark's lab,
he put me on a bench together
with another French guy.
And so our bench was called
the French Connection.
And there was
another bay, on which
there were two students, Tim
Mitchison-- with Professor
[? Nwataba ?] and Frank McKeon.
And the two of them
were pretty lousy.
So they were living--
you know, there
were dirty benches and things.
So we called it the Bay of Pigs.
But this turned out to be nice,
because I used the centrioles--
the team was purifying
centrioles from cells--
and I used the centrioles
that it was purifying
to do some experiments
in frog eggs,
to try to understand
how the spindle forms.
So then what we did,
it was very primitive.
We just injected centrosomes
into frog eggs which
were either in interphase.
So we could block the eggs
in interphase or in mitosis.
And when we injected
centrosomes in interphase,
we got very nice astrals--
so the nucleated
microtubules, as expected,
they form astrals
like in any cell.
But in mitosis,
nothing happened.
We did not see any astrals.
And we were very surprised,
because we could still
see the spindle--
the meiotic spindle
anyway in the egg.
So it meant that the
microtubules could assemble
around the chromosomes, but
the centrosomes could not
nucleate microtubules.
And at the time this
was very strange,
because everybody
thought that centrosomes
were organizing the spindle.
So what I did then was
to inject nuclei of cells
without centrosomes into
frog eggs in interphase
and in mitosis.
And around each
nucleus, I got a spindle
assembling around chromosomes.
So this was, for us,
it was really exciting,
because it was, really,
the chromosomes that
induced the machine that
is going to distribute them
to the two daughter cells.
So when I came back
to EMBL, I wanted
to continue working on this.
And with a postdoc, actually--
Rebecca Heald was
previously a student
of Frank McKeon, who
was a student of Mark.
So you see there is a
history behind of people.
And we put DNA onto
beads and put these beads
into frog egg extracts.
And spindle assembled in
vitro around the beads.
And when you look at the
formation of the spindle
by video, you see
that it's really
a self-organizing system.
It's really amazing.
The microtubules grow
from the chromatin.
And they self-organize
into a bipolar spindle.
So they are not very
nice here because this
is stuck on a [INAUDIBLE]
to have quantitative data.
But they can be really
beautiful, actually,
like normal spindles.
This whole observations
led me to the question
of self-organization in general.
And it's easy to talk
about self-organization.
But if you want to really
understand how it works,
you have to understand what
self-organization is based on.
So there are basically
two principles
that lead to the emergence
of patterns in systems.
One is collective behavior
and energy dissipation.
So there was very
old experiments.
If you heat liquid from below
in a thin layer like here,
at the beginning, when you
increase the temperature,
the water molecules
behave randomly.
So you don't see anything.
But suddenly they start to
behave in a coherent way.
So the molecules of
water form cylinders.
They form really
regular cylinders.
But these cylinders are
dynamic, so they exist just
because water molecules--
it's convection.
They are moving all the time,
but they move collectively
together so that
a pattern emerges.
The second mechanism
is reaction-diffusion.
And the first experiments were
done by Belousov-Zhabotinsky.
By chance, Belousov once
mixed two chemicals.
And these chemicals, instead--
normally if you mix
blue with white,
you get something
intermediate, or red and white,
you get some kind
of other color.
But when he mixed
these two chemicals,
they generated waves or
patterns that were steady state.
They kept oscillating,
or they formed patterns.
So at the time, people
did not believe this,
because it looked like it was
violating the second principle
of thermodynamics.
But finally this was
accepted, because they really
demonstrated that it worked.
And in fact, it's
Turing-- you know,
the guy who actually
invented the computer--
who developed the theory
of the reaction-diffusion.
And reaction-diffusion is,
in fact, two molecules react.
They defuse.
And one of the
molecules that defuse
feeds back into the
reaction and inhibits it.
So therefore this can
oscillate or generate patterns.
So and also, at a
different scale,
if you look at the
formation of fish shoals,
it is also a
self-organized system.
Because the fish
look at each other.
They like to swim together,
so they come to each other.
They don't like to be
too close to each other.
So they move apart.
And this is this plus
the speed that determines
the shape of the shoal.
So it's not one fish
that tells the shoal,
we should go that direction.
It's the collective behavior
of the fish that determines
the shape of the shoal.
So I though that
something like this
was going on, too, for the
organization of the spindle.
And we started to look
for what it could be.
So I was wondering
what in the chromosomes
could get the microtubules
to grow just around them.
And one day, Iain Mattaj at
EMBL was working on the nucleus.
And he came to me and said,
I have a small protein
called Ran, which can be
induced at a high energy
state or low energy state.
And this one may be involved
in the assembly of the spindle.
So he had a lot of
tools to study this.
And we could demonstrate that,
in fact, this was the case.
So this molecule, when
it is in the GTP state--
high energy state--
generates a gradient.
So this generates a gradient
around the chromosomes
that signals the
microtubules they
should grow in this region.
And this forms a
gradient, because this
is a reaction-diffusion system.
So we demonstrated this,
actually, theoretically.
So there is a molecule in
the chromosomes that loads
GTP on the Ran, and a
molecule in the cytoplasm that
transforms GTP into
GDP, so that you
have a reaction here--
reaction-diffusion
around the chromosomes.
So this generates
a gradient that
leads to local assembly
of microtubules.
So this was the first part to
understand how the chromosomes
induce spindle assembly.
Now the second question
was, how do the microtubules
get organized into a bipolar
structure-- into a shape?
And here I worked with
physicists Stan Leibler
and his postdocs.
And so what we did is to develop
a simple theoretical system.
They did experiments
like this, actually.
But then we did it
in the computer.
So we know that microtubules
can bind to motors--
the molecular motors that
move along the microtubules
by using energy.
And some of the motors can move
to one end of the microtubules
and others to the other.
But they can crosslink
microtubules, also.
So by playing with
the parameters--
the speed, the
probability with which
they bind to microtubules,
the speed of movement,
and various things--
we could start to build
a computer simulation
to see what happens
when you mix motors
and microtubules randomly
and how the system evolves.
And what you see is that
under certain conditions,
you get a formation of
self-organized asters,
or vortices, or sometimes
networks of microtubules
that look like
spindles a little bit.
And then, just to
show you live what
happens-- so these are
very old simulations.
So you start from
random system, and you
get a very organized
pattern spontaneously.
So the typical
self-organized system.
And if you change the
parameter of the system,
you can get others patterns,
for example, vortices,
as you can see here.
So at the end, they
managed to actually--
with Rebecca in another
postdoc, Francoise, actually--
model the spindle completely.
So this is beautiful,
because this is based on--
there are parts of the
simulation are determinist,
but most of it's
just stochastic.
So it's stochastic interaction
between information
rich molecules that leads
to the self-organization
of the spindle.
And you can model
it in the computer.
So we really have understood
how the system works.
So this is very important,
because we really understand
morphogenesis at this level.
OK.
Now, we have understood the
assembly of the spindle.
But then I thought, there is
something very interesting.
Because we can generate
spindles without chromosomes.
There are ways of doing this.
So when you generate
spindles without chromosomes,
they have no function.
But when they are
interacting with chromosomes,
the function emerges from the
interaction of the microtubules
with the chromosomes.
So I really like this, because
this is really going back
to the question of Kant.
Cell shapes self-organize
from stochastic interactions
between information
rich molecules.
Complex functions
emerge from interactions
between self-organized shapes.
And function results
from contingency.
There is no "goal and end."
So it's just the fact
that they are microtubules
and the chromosomes that
the function emerges
from this system.
The chromosomes don't know
they want the microtubules
to segregate them.
It's just that the whole
segregates the chromosomes.
And it just happens.
Philosophically, I think it's
really important to understand
this, because this is the
fundamental question of life,
actually, is, how do we get
to do what we do from nothing?
And then if you start to
look at cells in general,
our body is made of many cells.
We have 200 cell types.
They are different shapes.
And these shapes are
largely determined
by the cytoskeleton--
so microtubules
and the filaments, the filaments
which are forming your muscles,
also.
And depending on the state of
the cytoplasm of the cells,
you can generate
different types of shapes.
And this is amazing, because we
have 200 different cell types,
but this is one genome.
So it's not the
genome that decides
on the shape of the cells.
It's using the genome
in a certain environment
you can generate a
specific set of shapes.
This is very important,
because, for all the people
who work on genomics and things
like this, don't forget that.
This is complicated.
I mean, you cannot understand
life by just sequencing.
OK.
So now I just want to go
beyond that a little bit.
I want to say something about--
extend this a bit to the
embryogenesis program.
So how do you get from a ball to
the first shapes of the embryo,
and then to the
complexification of the embryo?
So this involves a lot of
symmetry breaking events.
You break the symmetry of--
the cells suddenly don't
interact in the same way
they were interacting before.
And the collective
cell behaviors.
There are feedback loops,
also, like reaction-diffusion
processes, and spatio-temporal
forward feedback processes.
I will show you what--
it's complicated--
I'll just show you what
it is with a nice example.
I will take an example,
which a group did in the EMBL
in the Department
of Cell Biology,
they did these experiments,
which are beautiful.
So this is a fish.
And you see here
the fish, actually,
they feel each other
by the lateral line.
So the same formation
of fish I showed before
is because they can feel
the vibration of water.
And this is because in
the lateral line here
they have small
sensory organs that
have cilia that
feel the movement
of the water next to them.
So Darren, who has been
doing these experiments,
he was filming the formation
of this lateral line.
And he saw that in fact,
this is a collective of cells
that move along a path
that has been deposited
before this stage
during embryogenesis.
So when the embryo was before--
a line of chemotactic
molecules has been
deposited on the muscles here.
And then this
collective that moves
from behind the ear
moves toward the tail
along this chemotactic trail.
Now, the first
thing you think is
that there is a
gradient on this trail
and that the cells
feel the gradient.
But in fact, Darren showed
that there is no gradient.
Because what he did was
to cut the trail here.
And the collective,
instead of keep
going because the
trail is cut here,
turn around and
start to move back.
So the collective feels a
trail, but it must generate
the gradient by itself--
so that self-generated gradient.
So I hired a student who did,
actually, the theory of this.
And he developed a
theory that demonstrated
how the gradient
is self-generated
at the front of the cells.
And then, in fact,
this was beautiful.
Because the theory actually
described in the same time
why the collective was
breaking up and forming organs
like this behind the
moving collective.
So what we know
is cell shapes are
determined by a complex network
of cytoskeleton molecules.
Forms and functions emerge
from stochastic events.
And cell forms
richness originates
from stochastic events.
So now, then the thing is that
cell form richness probably
originates from
complexification processes
during geological times.
And collective cell behaviors
and branching events
allow for extensive
variation of forms
in multicellular organisms.
So what this means is that what
we see now is very complex.
We see these complex cells.
We know that before it
was not so complex--
that there was only
bacteria, viruses,
relatively simple things.
So we have to understand
how complexity emerged.
So if you look at the diversity
of oceanic cell shapes,
now, it's just amazing.
That's pictures we took
with the confocal microscope
of different cells.
And you see a whole
zoo of patterns.
These are unicellular cells
that live only in the oceans.
And they live,
usually, not alone.
They live in symbiosis with
many other small cells.
And we don't understand
how all these shapes
are generated, actually.
How the complexity-- why is
there so many different cell
shapes?
So if you look at
evolution now, you
know life started about
four billion years ago.
And there was no oxygen. So
it was mostly carbon dioxide
and nitrogen. Then probably,
bacteria and viruses
lasted for about
2.5 billion years.
And then some
photosynthetic bacteria
started to emerge
during this time.
They produced the
oxygen. That started
to oxygenate the atmosphere.
And eukaryotes started
around this time, also.
So cells like us, with a
nucleus and a complex cytoplasm.
But the complexification of life
actually occurred pretty late.
I mean, around almost
at the same time
as the oxygen concentration
increased to about 20%.
And then you get protists,
animals, and plants,
first in the oceans.
And then they
populated the earth.
So here is just radiation.
And you see that
the protist actually
represent a lot of the
diversity that exists on earth.
And you are here, human
beings, close to mushrooms.
And this is our branch.
And the rest is the protists.
I've been thinking
a lot about this,
based on what I did
at the cellular level.
I was wondering if evolution
was really working the way
we think--
basically, by simple
variation and selection.
And I think that it's much
more complicated than this,
and that there are lots of
interaction between cells,
organisms, that lead to the
generation of complicated DNA
patterns and
cellular structures.
So the Tara Oceans,
in this context,
is kind of related
to this, because we
wanted to understand how all
these organisms have been
generated, how the DNA has been
complexified during this time,
and things like this.
So we thought that it would
be interesting to collect
these organisms
during an expedition.
But all the organisms--
you know, very often
the people who go mine biology
collect one type of organism.
Here we wanted to
collect everything
to see how all these
organisms interact
and how the environment actually
affect their interaction
or their behavior.
So to do that we needed to
collect all these organisms,
but also the data
about water mass,
carbon concentration, oxygen,
salinity, temperature,
or depth--
various kinds of parameters.
So the other thing is
that the ocean is complex.
And I think this has
probably been very important
for evolution.
There is a global circulation
that is modeled here by NASA.
You see the Gulf Stream here.
And each big oceanic basin
has a gyre or multiple gyres.
So the water is
circulating all the time.
So this circulation actually
transports the organism
all the time from one
point to the next.
So it transports organisms from
warm waters to cold waters,
from surface to depth.
So they keep being exposed
to different environments
and to different organisms.
So you can think of
the ocean somehow
as a huge washing machine
that mixes the organisms all
the time.
And in fact, I'll
just show you a movie
that shows the distribution
of different organisms.
And right here
there are diatoms,
which are small
unicellular photosynthetic
organisms, in blue.
Also large organisms,
synechococcus bacteria--
different types of bacteria.
So this is a model
Darren modeled, actually,
that has been generated by
Mick Follows here at MIT here.
And what Mick does is basically
seeds the ocean in a computer--
the ocean of the Earth with
a mixture of organisms.
At the beginning we have
homogeneous distribution.
And with time, the organisms
distribute like this.
So the whole distribution
of the life in the ocean
self-organizes into
a pattern, also.
In order to study this we needed
to develop a method to sample.
And I discussed with Etienne
Bourgois and [INAUDIBLE]
who are owning Tara.
This is a 36 meter
schooner which
can be equipped for
doing sampling of biology
and biophysical parameters.
So we developed a complex
sampling procedure.
So the organisms have
very different sizes.
So if you look at viruses,
[INAUDIBLE],, bacteria,
and archaea, they measure
between 0.02 microns
to something like
5 microns maximum.
And there are quite a lot of
them per liter of seawater.
So in 100 liter of ocean water,
you can get enough material
to work on these organisms.
But when the organisms
become larger,
there are less organisms
per liter of seawater,
so you need to collect
more water to analyze them.
And for the larger
ones are metazoa,
so organism made
of multiple cells,
you need to collect
quite a bit of water,
like 100 liters of seawater,
to get enough material
to work with them.
So we develop different methods.
So to collect these
organisms, you
can pump water and filter it,
or collect it with bottles.
But for the larger ones,
you have to use nets.
So you use nets of
different mesh sizes
that allow to collect the
organisms by size classes.
So we collected a lot of
different size classes here.
And each of the size class
has been analyzed separately,
which makes it easier to
sequence the genes of look
at them by microscopy.
So the boat left
in September 2009.
We sailed across the
Mediterranean Sea, the Red Sea,
the Indian Ocean, the South
Atlantic Ocean, Antarctica,
South Pacific, North Pacific.
And then we came
back to Lorient.
And in 2013 we sailed back to
sail around the North Pole.
And during all this trip, each
dot here is a sampling site.
So we decided to sample that
way because of the current I
showed before.
The sampling has
been very structured,
relative to the oceanography
we knew about the currents
and also the water masses.
Because for example, in
the north of Indian Ocean,
there is a region
which is very acidic
and which is very
poor in oxygen, also,
as well as the East Pacific.
So there are very
different water masses.
And it was very
important to collect
in these different
water masses to be
able to correlate
the ecosystem we were
sampling with the environment.
And the idea was to
analyze these samples using
modern technology, obviously.
So we used metagenomics
to characterize--
you see, myself, although
I said that genomics is not
so interesting, we did
a lot in Tara Oceans.
We sequenced the metagenomics.
This means that each filter
we got from one station
was basically sequenced.
So we get the DNA
sequence, the RNA sequence.
And we also collected samples
to do in parallel imaging.
So we could
characterize ecosystems
both at the genomic level
and at the morphology level.
And we obviously had all the
environmental parameters.
So all this work led
to a publication--
we have many more publications
since then-- but in 2015,
we published five
papers together,
where we showed
what we could get
from these kinds of samples.
I'll show you now, briefly,
the data we collected.
So this is viruses.
So I'll show what
we found by kingdom.
So this is the analyses of
the viruses around the world
and around the pole here.
And we found something like
480,000 viral populations.
And the interesting thing
is that only 19% of this
was known.
So this is huge.
I mean, it means that
there was nothing
done, basically, on
viruses before Tara
Oceans in the open ocean.
And you can do a
lot with this data.
And one of the things that
I found really interesting
is that these viral
populations cluster nicely
into five ecological zones.
For example, the yellow ones
correspond to the population
here--
correspond to temperate and
tropical epipelagic water.
The pink one corresponds
to temperate and tropical
mesopelagic-- so
around 600 meters deep.
Bathypelagic is very deep.
So it's those ones.
And the grey are
Antarctic region.
And Arctic regions are in blue.
You see, it's amazing how these
populations cluster together.
I was completely
surprised when I saw this.
The viruses are very
constrained by the environment.
Now, for the bacteria.
So these are all the stations
that have been sequenced.
And Shinichi Sunagawa
at EMBL and then
at ETH has characterized
47 million genes--
bacterium genes.
This is huge-- a
huge number of genes.
And again, using
these genes, you
can look at the importance
of various parameters
on the composition of the
genes, but also the composition
of the diversity of bacteria--
so the structure of ecosystems.
And one of the parameters
that dominates, actually,
to determine what kind
of bacteria live together
is temperature.
There is a linear relationship
between the temperature
and the composition of
the bacterial ecosystem.
Now for eukaryotes,
we found something
like 150,000 different
genuses of eukaryotes.
And we saturated the diversity
in the regions we went.
So this means that
we probably are not
far from the total number of
genuses in the surface ocean.
But when we look at the
genes, we found something
like 116 million unigenes.
And it doesn't saturate.
So we are far from saturation.
So there's much more
than 116 million unigenes
in the oceans--
eukaryotic.
And we calculated each
plateau around 190 million.
So this is a huge
number of genes.
And one of the things
we were interested in
was to see how the
organisms interact.
So you can, using
bioinformatics,
you can see on the
global data set,
you can see who
interacts with whom
and who excludes each other.
So there is very
little organisms
that exclude each other.
You see here the exclusion
rate is about 20%.
And 80% of the
organisms live together.
So it does mean that
they necessarily need,
but a lot of them
should interact in order
to function probably.
And you can see
this using imaging.
So what you see here
is, for example,
a ciliate, which lives in
symbiosis with another protist.
And here, lots of
different protists,
and each of them-- almost
no protist lives alone.
Most of the time, they
live in symbiosis,
or at least there are organisms
interacting with them.
So it's extremely complex.
And with this data,
which is amazing,
you can look at
how they interact.
For example, this
one, the ciliate,
which has the symbiodinium
as a symbiont,
you can look at different
places in the world
and try to see
whether this is always
the same species of symbiodinium
and ciliate that live together.
And you find variations.
So there are specific locations.
The interaction
changes according
to where you are in the ocean.
So what I want to
get at now, just
to finish this
presentation, is, how
did life complexify
over the, probably,
the last billion years?
I mean, it comes
in pretty simple
for probably two or
three billion years.
But then in the last billion
years it became very complex.
So in order to make a simple
cell, we know we need about,
probably--
perhaps less, but--
something like 500 genes.
A human being is
made of 20,000 genes.
And we found in the
ocean 200 million genes.
The real problem of
evolution, in my opinion,
is really complexification--
how all these genes have
been generated-- not
only all these genes,
but how all these organisms.
Because as you have seen
in the previous slides,
the protists-- there are lots
of protists that live together.
So they form complex systems.
We live with
bacteria in our gut.
So it's a real problem.
I mean, we have to
understand how this happened.
It's not only, obviously, simple
variation with point mutations,
or things like
this, and selection.
It's much more
complex than this.
So we need to work
on this, I think.
I don't know yet how,
but this is important.
So the question is,
how far back can we
go with Tara Oceans data?
How did gene transfers,
duplications, recombinations,
mutations, and
cellular interactions
contribute to life
complexification?
I think they are
important questions.
How to predict evolution,
structure, and distribution
of planktonic ecosystems?
And another aspect I
did not talk about,
but which is very important,
is that these ecosystems
have a very strong impact on
the geochemical processes that
shape our atmosphere.
And by knowing this we can
start to better understand
how the ocean
regulates our climate.
Now, I would like just to
finish on one slide, which
is a little complicated, but--
to relate self-organization
and evolution.
There's a big debate between
classical evolutionary people
who are stuck with the idea
of variation and selection.
And people think
that evolution itself
is a self-organization
process, just as
what I described at
the cellular level
but at a much bigger scale.
I think it works like that, too.
But we have to find
out how to study that.
So we know that
self-organization involves
different principles
like collective behavior,
and reaction-diffusion--
obviously,
at the scale of
two million years,
it's not reaction-diffusion.
But it's probably transport.
So organism interaction
and transport
are probably very important--
have been very important--
for evolution, at least
at the cellular level.
And combinatorial processes
like functional modules
in cells and
organism interaction
are probably also key to the
generation of complexity.
Selection is
extremely important,
but it has mostly a
rule of elimination.
So it eliminates the
things that don't work.
So I think that if we want
to go into the understanding
of evolutionary processes,
especially early evolution,
like the generation of the
complexity of life in the ocean
before we came about--
which is important, because
most of the regulatory networks
that we are built on have
been formed in the ocean--
we need to work on
these kind of questions.
So just to finish, I would
like to thank lots of people.
So these are a part of the
people who have participated
in Tara Ocean.
And these are very-- you know
Mark here-- lots of people
who have been
working on in my lab
and with different collaborators
throughout the world.
I must say, being a scientist--
I know some people are
not scientists here--
but being a scientist
is really a chance.
Because we meet a lot of
people and great people.
So it's wonderful.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I have a question.
Wonderful talk.
I was interested in
virus segregation.
So virus are also
depending on the host.
So virus segregate,
maybe, differently
from the other organisms
that you have found.
Or that means that they
can infect different hosts.
And the other thing
is, can you use
virus that are so sensitive
to the environment
and physical chemical changes as
an indicator of climate change
or changing in the oceans?
- So yes, viruses are actually
depending on the host.
And I skipped this
slide, actually.
But what determines the virus
population somewhere is,
there is a source, usually.
So the viruses are produced
where there is a lot of hosts.
For example, in
the South Atlantic,
there is a source of viruses
close to Benguela Upwelling,
because there are lots of
bacteria there for the phages.
And then we could show with
Tara how they are transported--
how they populate a certain
region from various regions.
So the hosts play a
very important role
here-- so global distribution.
Now, if we can use viruses for
climate change, I don't know.
We have not looked
at this at all.
The only thing we know is
that all these organisms
are extremely sensitive
to temperature.
The bacteria, the eukaryotes--
a 1 degree change in
temperature changes
completely the ecosystem.
And you see there is this
very tight relationship
between temperature and
bacterial communities.
So I think the viruses is
probably the same, because they
depend on the host.
- I will ask a question.
So as a physicist--
and if you have questions,
please come to the microphone,
but I'll ask this
question first.
- OK.
- So just come over here.
Can you?
OK.
Thank you.
So anyway, as a
physicist, I'm obsessed
with very accurate time.
And I noticed that in some of
the processes that you were
saying were being regulated,
at least from the videos,
it looked like the
periodicity was not
in an exact number of seconds.
And I'm just wondering whether
that was true, first of all,
and whether it's kind of an
almost periodic cell division--
- You mean-- what was periodic?
- So you showed
the cell division
happening in the early work--
- Yeah.
It did look like--
yeah, yeah.
It's completely-- very precise.
- Is it an exact interval
of time, or sort of exact?
- No.
Mark?
It's very precise, I think.
I don't remember, but I--
- In the first one,
there's a [INAUDIBLE]..
So there's a
[INAUDIBLE] for that.
- That's what I
was going to ask.
I was going to ask,
is there any hint
in the organization
of the behavior,
the self-organization, in how
accurately things are timed?
In other words, can you--
- Essentially, we [INAUDIBLE].
Then they will still
be like still clocks.
So each one of them
has a [INAUDIBLE]..
- They're separate clocks.
- Separate--
- We understand the clock now.
- The clock's
distributed from there.
And then you
separate [INAUDIBLE]..
- Fascinating.
- We understand how the clock
works, more or less, now.
OK.
- My question is more about
mechanics of the whole thing.
And that is, it's a sailboat.
How much of the time is
it actually under sail,
and how much of time--
- With the boat?
- And how much of it is motored?
And do the currents help
move you along, too?
- It depends.
In Tara Oceans, we sailed about
50% of the time with the sails.
In the Pacific, you sailed
about 80% with the engine, no?
So in the Pacific, it
was more complicated,
so we had to use
the engine a lot.
- I have a question
about your sampling
technique for microorganisms.
Clearly you deal mostly, as far
as I can see, with the surface,
with the photosphere.
What about lower depths, where
there's very little light,
different microorganisms?
- I did not get your--
- Depths of 80,
100, 200 meters--
- So we sampled at the surface.
And at 50, 70 meters.
And around 600 meters.
So 600 meters is
called mesopelagic.
So that's interesting, because
the life at the surface
is completely different
from the life at 600 meters.
It's not the same organisms
at all, which is normal,
because at the
surface they live off
the photosynthesis of the light.
But at 600 meters they live
off what dies at the surface
and falls down.
So it's a completely
different system.
- Thank you.
And do the virus
populations mix?
Or are they also stratified?
- No, they are stratified also.
Yeah.
- Thank you.
- My question is a
follow on to his.
How deep, eventually,
do you plan
to be able to pull up
specimens, considering water
pressure and the
difficulties of lowering
collection tubes, or
whatever, into the dark depths
of the ocean?
- Yeah.
We start out, we cannot
sample very deep.
Not because of
pressure or anything.
It's just because the
boat is too small.
We need large machines
to collect deep.
But there is another
boat, a big boat, which
was used by Spanish scientists.
And in the same time as
we did this expedition,
they collected
samples very deep--
4,000 meters, close
to the bottom.
4,000 to 6,000 meters.
So it's feasible.
It requires some technology,
but you can do it.
- I want to come back
to the mechanisms
of self-organization.
One essential
principle I thought
was missing in your talk
was phase separation.
I think it was there
in an implicit way.
But phase separation is
a principle of demixing--
- Yes, absolutely.
- --something that was
randomly mixed before.
And doesn't that
potentially lead,
or is an essential
mechanism for, speciation?
- Aha.
That's a good idea.
For speciation,
yes, it could be.
Yeah, we don't talk about
phase separation here,
but it's also
extremely important
here for self-organization
processes.
We could use this
concept probably for--
I did not think
about this, but this
would be very interesting
to look into this here,
to see whether the
species separate-- yeah,
it's interesting.
Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
- So I think we will end there.
And we have a
reception downstairs.
So please stick
around, talk with Eric
if you have further questions,
talk with the sailors
if you want to know more
about life on board,
the life on the high seas.
And please join me in thanking
Eric for a superb lecture.
[APPLAUSE]